what's going on guys national master
james canton iii here with chess.com and
today we have game of the day
leela chest zero versus stock fish
let's get right into it it's very
exciting and leela chess started with e4
stockfish responds with c5 now guys this
game went
87 moves very long game so let's get
through all the moves e4 c5
knight f3 knight to c6 d4
c takes and knight takes d4 we have a
standard sicilian here
usually positions start like this all
the time with the d4 pawn and knight
takes d4
and many sicilians as we know knight f6
knight to c3
d6 and now instead of anything else we
actually went with bishop to c4 here
from leela chess which is the chosen
part of the seven engine variation
so this is the sozen and the sodium is
very very aggressive when you play
bishop to c4
intending for sacrifices on f6 or even
e6 if they do play it and that's what
stockfish plays e6 here
and sometimes you can sacrifice on e6 it
just depends on what's going on
usually it's more prone to be sacrificed
on if you have knight b
on knight b to d7 happening for black
here but in this position we're still
going to play on we need to develop our
pieces
we always have to develop no matter what
opening we're playing bishop e3 bishop
e7
we need two queens off the back rank and
now we're preparing to castle to either
side
most likely queen side in these type of
positions so after a6
and tending b5 and just getting the
counter play going on the queen side
because we're probably going to have an
opposite side castles here and whoever
gets to the king first in these kind of
positions is going to win so a6
castle queen side queen to c7 just
putting some uncomfortable
x-ray indirect pressure here on the king
on c1
also the bishop here that's slightly
loose due to the queen only defending at
once
and the queen really doesn't want to be
here defending this that much so after
queen c7 we see bishop to b3
then there's castles rick h the g1
and the knight d7 now this rook has to
g1 move i really like because it's
it's uh x-raying the the king here on
the g file we're also threatening g4 and
many other cases many things can happen
here knight to d7 and tending knight to
c5
and also getting the knight out of the
way maybe bishop f6 can happen and uh
put this bishop on a very strong
diagonal
is very close to the b2 pawn which is
close to the king so we just want to
start aiming on the side of the board
let's see what white does we intend g4
again whoever gets to the king first is
going to win here
black plays knight to c5 and now pause
the video what would you actually play
here is leela chess
what would you play here as leela chess
zero
white to move if you chose knight f5 you
are 100 correct
wow what a move i didn't even see this i
didn't even think about it
because knight five just looks so
different it doesn't even look like it's
going to work
but it actually does in many lines of
course leela chess
zero is just a monster of a engine but
with knight f5
on the board here uh stockfish didn't
even take it and here's the thing with
knight f5
if we take this away the problem here
there's an open g file bishop h6s are
coming
also this pawn is going from e6 which is
uh declaring space or actually
stopping anything from coming into the
d5 square well not anymore the knight
can go to d5 now and actually hit the
queen
and the bishop and intend on maybe even
putting something on f6
bringing the queen over to h5 oh my
goodness look at the arrows right
and we're not done yet so knight f5 is
on the board very strong move here
and stockfish says i'm not taking that
knight b5
so knight takes e7 because we're not
going to allow them to take it at the
right moment so we just eliminate the
bishop here and get our knight off of f5
and put him on to e7 queen takes e7 and
then you want to make threats so we make
queen to d2
just better placing the queen hitting d6
and also intending maybe even bishop g5
or h6 let's see what black plays work to
d8 to defend
and then we have bishop g5 beautiful
move here i like this this move right
here
sometimes guys you have to provoke a
weakness in the king's
camp in the castle in the castle side
camp of your opponent so that uh
they have weaknesses you have things you
can hit anchors and like pawn levers and
stuff like that so f6
and then bishop back to e3 we've
provoked a weakness and now after we
provoke the weakness
well now we're going to attack the
weakness the f6 pawn
g5 beautiful play here whoever gets to
the king first is going to win
and it looks like white is in the
driver's seat on this preparing to open
the g
file this bishop's a monster we even
have f4 maybe even swinging the queen
over to help out
as well let's see what happens next b4
black is like i need
some counter play right now so lila
chess takes on f6
now if we take on c3 that fails not to
pawn take c7
but actually to queen takes f6 which is
defending the f6
pawn also threatening rook takes g7
check and
threatening the queen at the same time
if the queen captures on f6 then we
capture back ourselves on f6
and due to the pin on the g file black
just lost the queen
so g takes f6 queen takes f6 we don't
want to go into the complications here
and leela chess is like i need something
to do here like i don't have any really
really good moves besides just moving
the knight
knight to a4 knight takes e4 is here
queen to e2
rook f8 hitting the f2 pawn with just a
little bit of pressure here
and then we bait them into bringing the
queen in a little bit closer
while also kicking the knight
simultaneously f3
queen takes f3 bishop takes e6 check and
then king 2ha
alright guys right here we're move 23
and there's about
60 moves left from here a lot of chess
being played here
and i mean you can almost it's almost
unbelievable the stockfish
or it can survive or anyone could
survive this position um
60 more moves from here guys now in this
position
leela chess played an awesome move an
awesome
move guys what would you play in this
position pause the video can you find
the move
that leela chess played in this position
here we go guys leela chess played
bishop h6
whoa what a move bishop h6 what is going
on isn't my queen hanging
yes it is but we don't care about that
because checkmate is better
bishop takes g7 check mating the king on
the spot beautiful move
and if pawn takes h6 well tactics win
games rook g8 check
and it's a diversion here rook has to
take and then queen takes
f3 and we go up a queen like really nice
material
balance there beautiful move stockfish
says not today plays g5
queen takes f3 rook takes f3 bishop
takes g5
and then when we get to this position
here guys you make a few moves rook
takes
now look at this position black kind of
got out of this now of course stockfish
is a very strong engine as we know
but with that being said guys this is a
pretty not not that it's equal but
black's feeling a little bit better
than what he was moves ago almost
getting crushed
so rook to g8 trying to trade rook g to
e1
put the rick's only open files it's
always best to just put rooks on open
files right
rook to f8 just defending the knight and
also rook to e7
is the next move for white here so
rookie seven hitting the bishop we have
the seventh rank this h7 pawn is kind of
weak you just have to create threats and
be a very
very annoying to your opponent bishop to
c8 i'm coming to the better diagonal
here
then we have knight to b6 bishop g4
we're gonna fly through some moves here
guys uh because we do have 50 moves left
even from here knight to d7 rook to c8
uh we trade a pair of uh rooks here and
now check this out guys
black to move all right am i taking the
knight am i taking the knight on d7
or am i taking the rook on d1 which one
am i playing
what would you play here if you were
stock fish guys which way
here we go black actually takes on d1
instead if bishop takes uh if bishop
takes d7
we have rook takes d6 hitting the bishop
and the a6 pawn and it's just a better
winning end game actually here for white
it's going to take some technique of
course but it is winning so now we
actually choose bishop takes d1 which is
very very interesting here
now we do have two the two pieces for
the rook here and we're even on ponds so
we need a plan you always need a plan a
bad plan is better than no plan at all
so here we need to make sure we try to
trade some of the pawns off
we want to be left with a pawn or two
and we want to capture some of their so
that we're up
a pawn or two and we're going to queen
them based off the nature of the
position let's see what happens
king takes d1 king to g7 bishop to d5 i
just centralized the bishop
rook to c7 attack tonight we move the
knight or actually we can play bishop to
e62 as well but also
knight b6 is a move and um knight to b8
but bishop to uh bishop to e6 was a very
nice
into h6 and then king to d2 king g5
knight b6 and now we're trying to swing
the knight back around into play here
there was a lot of shuffling so let's
move through some moves here rookie 7
bishop c4 hitting a6
we're also going to back up here and
solidify the bishop make it very strong
here while also hitting the h7 pawn
king h4 nxt says oh you know what my my
h pawns defend it we're gonna go for
yours and try to snag this
immediately white's trying to grab as
many pawns as we can so we go knight to
c4
attacking the d6 pawn attacking the a5
pawn h5 is played and we're going to
take the eight by pawn
now here i would actually take the
d-pawn of course i think humans would do
this just taking the d-pawn
it just feels like it's a little bit
better here but actually in in
in a in game since you think about it
guys knight takes a5 we take this these
pawns
are now separated these are stronger so
if you take on d6 these are still a
little bit strong this is the best move
knight takes a5
rook to c7 and then bishop to f1 nice
move here
cutting the king off from actually
hitting the h2 pawn so we're goes to f7
i want to get to that pawn as quickly as
possible and then we defend it
king e2 try again try again black says
well rook a7
knight to c4 now and now yeah he can get
a pawn here but we can also grab one
ourselves here but he actually didn't
take the pawn here stockfish did not
take on a2 here
many humans would take on a2 but
stockfish did not and after king to g5
we actually just defended the pawn and
says
no you're not going to take it a second
time a3 is on the board and then d5
happens so
if you move the knight i take the pawn
so we have to move the knight if we want
to keep material even
now or or even better here keep the
material advantage we have knight to e3
b takes a3 b takes a3 rook a5 very
nice in between move just defending
seeing what white's going to do so we're
going to just attack this pawn
continuously
k2 f4 we're going to take on d5 because
it's with check and here we go
knight to b4 and we have now reached the
position that we want guys we said we
want to trade off pawns
we want to get to a position where we
can clean some of these pawns
so let's see what happens here this is
the last piece or the pawn that we need
to get rid of or at least try to
in the sense black plays h4 he's coming
to him just a little bit closer here but
sometimes that's not a good idea because
91 immediately is now threatening knight
f3
trying to take on h4 so stockfish
replies h3
you are not going to take this pawn that
easy dr bishop to b7 which is a
beautiful move by the way
just moving away from the action the
rook is definitely going to come
threaten you we go knight f3 first and
look at this beautiful move after knight
f3
bishop to e4 defending everything
the pawn on c2 is defended the pawn on
h2 is defended the bishop defends the
knight and the king is going to come
around
and defend the bishop the king and
bishop are going to run over to the h
file
grab that pawn and we're going to clean
both of the that's the plan here let's
see what happened
this should be for rook to g7 in e3
remember we got to follow our plan here
it's time to take this pawn at king f4
rook h8 both of these pawns
you can't touch them if you wanted to
rook h8
bishop to f5 ac 4k g3
rook g8 check king takes h3 we are now
up two pawns
and we're technically up a piece here
yeah we're down in exchange with up a
piece
and we're feeling great let's see what
happens king to c3 engage four by leela
chess
in b4 by stockfish eh5 we'll run a
simple king walk here
rook to g2 h4 king c3 king g5 or knight
g5
king d4 kg6 all right so what we got
around and then we have the knight to
block it
this is nothing we're going to get here
so fast like king b2 and queen
it's easy it's over from this point so
let's see how we defend king e5 c4 push
the other one
wow pushing the other one rook f2
knight f7 check back the king off push
it again past pawns must be pushed
rook g2 king f6 and over to b2
h6 there's no way to stop this pawn guys
if you notice
no way to stop the pawn virtually over
rook to b2 pushing the pawn king e3 and
he just lets him clean
dogfish just says all right this is over
this is over
and glitch has queens but what's funny
is leela just didn't queen
c5 oh my goodness what an engine right
c5 you know i'm going to queen both of
them rook f2
king to the king to e7 and then rook to
f1
c6 rook a1 c7 rook a5 and then the
rook's just moving around at this point
then we have a check then we have
another check here this is one of the
engine moves or the computer moves as
they would say because it's just this is
hopeless here so they go for the one
last shot here of check
and then bishop takes king f3 queen h3
and we're gonna check mate in nice
fashion here with a queen on h1
what a game guys what a game what is
sicilian here from lila chess
going with knight f5 and then following
up with the bishop to h6
was wonderful this is how you rip open
the king's side
starting with the rook eights to g1 with
already having the idea of knight five
ambition to h6 to follow
beautiful game here guys this was leela
chess for leaderchest zero
versus stockfish i'm national master
james canty iii here with chess.com
and this was game of the day and i'll
see you guys on the next
video